library Archer is a design and lifestyle
library in the heart of Archie 10lb
wanted to engage as many users as it
could ever thought this was a fantastic
opportunity for us to use design
thinking design today is a way of design
value engage as many users as you can
and then in size so that it helps you
come with ideas that addresses their
real needs we wanted to hear from the
user from your point of view gather the
feedback and to create a library space
specifically for them calabria archer
design thinking was not just pivotal and
setting up the library but for the
library of continuing this and use it
when we implement our programs and
services so we came up with this concept
of the Wonderland and it's a wonderland
where you can go in and experience
design in many many different ways we
made it very welcoming it's the first
library that says hello we found out
that users really wanted to do three
things they wanted to learn and discover
to engage and rescue and all the
elements in the library built around
these three themes for example the
cocoon the cocoon is built for a single
person to sit inside and escape into his
world books the book tree is a platform
for users will come together and share
their thoughts about books and
literature even the book shelves they
are contoured to enhance the sense of
discovery and SK it comes down to small
things like the library etiquette so we
created some quite interesting
conversational ways of and even slightly
humorous ways of talking about etiquette
I think the president's design awards is
a great outreach for design notice
because it firms the visionary had the
process that we went through and the
hard work that everybody put it my
advice is to be true to yourself just
look at everything experience everything
and see that in the context of the
design that happens around you in the
world and understand that as well as you
can and then do your best to interpret
it in an interesting and inspiring way
true beauty is purity that pervades true
every single millimeter this beauty is
on the inside as well outside